i
love the the how you capture your
performance in both live action and
animation
uh how is that for you how do you get
into that mindset in a different medium
and do you treat it differently at all
well this one was especially important
and special because it's been my
lifelong dream
ever since i was a little kid to be in a
star wars project
and to finally have it happen and to be
given such a cool character you know i
didn't want to mess it up
so um for me first i took the
inspiration from fenix name
and i looked up what a fennec i didn't
realize that there was like this thing
called authentic fox
and um and then when i put on the
costume
for the first time i i it just
everything started falling into place
about who she was you know i love the
orange and there's orange in the fennec
fox so i went further with it and
you know fennec foxes have big ears and
they're very cunning and they're
listening all the time and they're
stealth
and loners so i took the essence of all
that
and um created this character um
you know uh had ideas about the hairdo
and maria was so great said oval
in helping me to make it happen
you know because i wanted the authentic
fox to have a tail
it's just like it was all just
figuring out her speech how she talked
you know all those things about who she
was
i had the best time creating her so then
when you take that
into voiceover for the bad batch is
it harder without the are you saying the
costume and all of the
practical stuff or how was it for you
well that was the great thing right
because i my character went from being a
live action
where i was able to create it and then
now i
only have to think about her as a
younger character and who that younger
character is
you know so i just pitched it up a
little bit not too much
because she has such a distinctive sound
and i i
for me it's just her her rhythm
when she speaks there's sometimes she
drags outwards a little bit
sometimes it's very purposeful
everything that she says
has a purpose to it you know so
so um and and then when she goes into
like these
characters because she's a great bounty
hunter you know she knows how to lure
and like when she was getting um
omega's trust you know she changes her
energy just a little bit
she becomes more nurturing you know
she's very chameleon
in that way um seeing as we haven't seen
the last of fennec in the live action
uh how do you connect what we are seeing
in the bad batch to what we see later
do you try to connect the dots in your
head do they tell you
uh the road that your character is
taking or how do you
a little bit of both you know we go into
a lot of discussions
um about uh the character and the
motivations for any scenes
and uh and and that's what's so great
about john favreau and dave filoni
and robert rodriguez you know we we are
in extremely collaborative and they're
so supportive in listening to
my ideas and and incorporating them you
know if it's appropriate and if
if we disagree about something you know
we we talk it out
it's um it's so wonderful to work with
some
we're with people who just genuinely
want to tell the best story
in the most honest way possible and
and you know that's what they are
they're they're great collaborators
how do you change anything how you
approach fennec in uh
the book of boba fett based on how you
did her in the bad batch
yeah i think one of the things i could
give away is that
you know fennec has always been a loner
and she's always not need she didn't
want to
need anyone and i think when she was
taken by surprise
when toro cal callahan killed her
not really injured her badly um
like any anyone you know for me i feel
like there's a sense of
vulnerability now and what can she do
to better her odds and chances of
staying alive
and so her decision to now
partner up with boba fett not just so
much because of the honor system
which is there she does have a code of
honor and ethics
which i love um it's also you know not
about paying back a debt
it's also about okay this might be my
next
you know my my next uh um
adventure is to partner up with someone
uh based on where we uh see fennec again
now in the
the the newest episode of the bad batch
where do you
uh think her head is at what what is she
thinking when like all of these like
she's
getting trapped sort of in a way that's
way bigger than what you thought of
in the beginning well um
i mean i i can't answer that
you tried to trap me into a stop that
i'm not supposed to say
almost you almost got me raphael um
well i mean all i can say is you know
she
she's smart she'll you know she whatever
situation she gets herself especially
because she is young
younger and more reckless and more
ruthless in some ways
you know and and more ambitious
um it's it's you know
she's learning every every every
experience that she's
had up until that point will either
help her through it and we know she
survives because she shows up
20 some years later so um
yeah it's interesting it's interesting
to to see what
she how how quickly she learns and and
how she adapts
um how you finish recording the gremlins
animated series and is there any or is
there anything you can tease about that
project
um gremlins uh we're still in the
process of of working on it
yes yes it's it's that you that you love
about that franchise that made you want
to join
because i love the gremlins you know i
mean i loved all those
types of movies growing up and they're
classics
i just watched it again with my kids
because they've never seen it
and i'd forgotten how crazy that movie
was i mean you know when they put the
gremlin in the blender i was like
damn or in the microwave i was like
you know there was some viciousness
going on there
but um but you know it's great it's it's
fantastic classical
projects and it's stuff that i grew up
with and
so now to have a chance to um be a part
of
my childhood like who doesn't want that
um going to book above the future of the
mandalorian what is one thing that you
really hope to see or that you really
like about where the story is going
well first of all i get to work with
chamuera
who i absolutely adore he's just
the most charming talented funny guy
and yet i love our dynamics because he's
very serious in in certain ways and i'm
the geek and the nerd and whenever i get
on set i go
crazy for five minutes like looking at
everything touching everything asking
the crew
or the props people about this or that
or you know wanting to steal things off
the set i'm just like
and then tim's always the one that's
like me let's work
[Laughter]
so i love i love getting a chance to
work with him
and robert rodriguez too i mean such a
huge fan
um if i was a fan of his before i'm even
a bigger fan now
and then of course john and dave you
know it's it's about that
it's it's being surrounded by really
amazing
talented people and uh and getting to
just be in more star wars things
yeah awesome thank you so much me a
pleasure talking to you
pleasure talking to you too